AUNT, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
YOU KNOW WHAT THESE ENDLESS
DEMOCRAT ATTACKS ON THE
PRESIDENT REMIND ME OF?
♪ ♪
>> Laura: THAT THEY THINK THEY
HAVE THEM ON THE CLIFF.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: THEY THINK THEY WILL
GET HIM ON THE MOVE.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: BUT IT ALWAYS ENDS
UP THE SAME WAY.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: IS THAT
ANDREW MCCABE?
STILL THE DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO
RESORT TO THE SAME FAILED
TACTICS AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT.
THEY SPENT $32 MILLION CHASING
THE FANTASY OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION
AND ALONG THE WAY TO CELEBRATED
A STRING OF BUFFOONS, KIND OF
CARTOON CHARACTERS IN AND OF
THEMSELVES, AS THEY IMAGINE
THESE PEOPLE WOULD ONCE AND FOR
ALL SLEIGH TRUMP.
FIRST THERE WERE THE TWO MICHAE
MICHAELS.
>> I BELIEVE ULTIMATELY HE WILL
BE FORCED TO RESIGN THAT IS
INFORMATION THAT IS GOING TO
COME TO LIGHT.
>> THIS DUDE RIGHT HERE, I THINK
OF HIM IN THE JUSTICE LEAGUE
WITH ROBERT MUELLER TO SAVE OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> THIS BEHAVIOR IS CHURLISH, IT
DENIGRATES THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT, AND IT IS SIMPLY
UN-AMERICAN.
>> PEOPLE ARE GOING TO START
FLIPPING I THINK THAT TRUMP
NEVER THOUGHT WOULD FLIP BEFORE.
>> THIS IS WHERE IT ENDS FOR
THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
I LOVE THE WAY -- THE DRAMATIC.
THEN THERE WAS MUELLER, THE
MESSIAH.
>> CAN REPEAT THE QUESTION?
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT PLEASE?
LEAVE IT WITH THE REPORT.
CAN YOU REPEAT THE LAST PART OF
THAT QUESTION?
>> Laura: ONE LAW AND ORDER
SPECIAL COUNSEL ADDITION WAS
CANCELED, THEY REVERTED TO THE
OLD STANDARD, YOU'RE A RACIST.
>> IS THE PRESIDENT A WHAT'S A
PHARMACIST?
>> HE IS.
HE'S ALSO MADE A VERY CLEAR.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS AND
WORDS HAVE CONVEYED A VERY
STRONG SENSE TO MANY, MANY
AMERICANS THAT HE HAS WHITE
SUPREMACIST LEAFS.
>> AND HE IS NOT ONLY EGGING ON
WHAT'S A PRIMACY AND WHITE
NATIONALISM, BUT HE IS ONE
HIMSELF.
>> WHAT MORE DO WE NEED TO SEE
OR HEAR FROM THIS RACIST MAN?
>> Laura: ALL THE WHILE THEY
CHALLENGE HIS EVERY POLICY AND
FEDERAL COURT AND ACTIVIST
JUDGES ISSUED NATIONWIDE
INJUNCTIONS STYMIEING ELEMENTS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
>> NATIONWIDE INJUNCTIONS
UNDERMINE THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
FROM OUR HISTORY AND TRADITION,
VIOLATE CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES AND IMPEACH SOUND OF
TRADITIONAL ADMINISTRATION ALL
OF THE COST OF PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
IN OUR INSTITUTIONS.
>> Laura: HEAR, HEAR, AND THIS
WEEK, THE DEMOCRATS ARE BACK TO
SQUARE ONE.
BANKING ON ANOTHER DISGRUNTLED
INSIDER TO TAKE DOWN TRUMP.
BUT WHISTLE-BLOWER REPORTEDLY
CLAIMS THAT TRUMP MADE A PROMISE
TO A FOREIGN LEADER.
TONIGHT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAY THAT
THIS INVOLVES THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE.
WE BARELY KNOW ANY OF THE FACTS
HE HADN'T, BUT THE LEFT IS
ALREADY ASSUMING THE WORST.
>> IT JUST GIVES ME CHILLS TO
HEAR YOU SAY THAT.
I MEAN, YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THEY'VE GOT
SOMETHING THAT'S INCREDIBLY
SENSITIVE.
>> IT'S ASTONISHING, I'VE NEVER
HEARD OF ANYTHING LIKE THIS AND
IT SHOULD BE DEEPLY TROUBLING TO
AMERICANS.
>> THIS DOES RISE TO A MUCH
HIGHER LEVEL OF CONCERN.
>> I THINK THIS COULD BE
SOMETHING CLOSER TO BETRAYAL.
>> Laura: IS THIS DEJA VU!
COME ON!
COME ON, DEMOCRATS DON'T
ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
DOES ANYONE REMEMBER WHAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S ATTITUDE
WAS TOWARDS WHISTLE-BLOWERS?
THE LIBERAL GUARDIAN NEWSPAPER
CHARACTERIZED IT THIS WAY.
OBAMA'S WAR ON WHISTLE-BLOWERS
LEAVES ADMINISTRATION INSIDERS
UNSCATHED.
AND THE AMERICAN MEDIA RESPONDED
WITH A COLLECTIVE YAWN TO ALL OF
THIS, BUT BOY, THEY ARE ALL
ABOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER TONIGH
TONIGHT.
THEY NEED SOMETHING, ANYTHING TO
AVOID TALKING ABOUT TRUMP'S
ACTUAL RECORD.
THE U.S. ECONOMY IS THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD AS EUROPE AND ASIA
SLIDE EVER TOWARDS RECESSION.
LET'S LOOK AT THE NEW OECD
PROJECTED GDP NUMBERS FOR 2019,
SHALL WE?
THE U.S. IS AT 2.4% GDP
PROJECTION, JAPAN, 1%, GERMANY
.5%, ITALY?
DOWN TO 0 AND THERE ARE MORE AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE BARREL.
WELL, WE ARE DOING BETTER THAN
ANY G-7 COUNTRY AND THE
AMERICANS KNOW IT, WE FEEL IT.
TRUMP'S APPROVAL RATING SPIKED
FOUR POINTS, 43%, LAST MONTH.
HIS APPROVAL AMONG REPUBLICANS
IS AT 91%.
THAT'S A PHENOMENAL
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
IMAGINE WHAT HIS OVERALL
APPROVAL NUMBERS WOULD BE IF WE
HAD A PRESS THAT WAS EVEN
MINIMALLY OBJECTIVE.
NOT ALL THE TIME, BUT LET'S SAY
30% OF THE TIME.
THE DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THAT THEY
CAN WIN THE WHITE HOUSE THROUGH
A COMBINATION OF DEMONIZATION
AND INVESTIGATION.
I SAY LET THEM HAVE AT IT.
IF TRUMP KEEPS RACKING UP
RESULTS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THE DEMOCRATS WILL COME UP